[Music]
[Applause]
nbc sunday night football notre dame
analyst super bowl mvp drew brees set to
join us on the program and drew will be
on the call notre dame hosting his alma
mater the boilermakers of purdue this
saturday that's at 2 30 eastern and then
football night in america he'll be on
that uh head of the chiefs ravens all on
nbc
and peacock and drew brees joins us
how's the weather in south bend indiana
i'm actually driving i'm driving uh
i just passed kokomo indiana i'm on
highway 31 north headed up to south bend
right now did notre dame recruit you
no they did
sounds like you're still holding a
grudge there
no no no yeah i
i no grudges i i'm a texas kid so i i
wanted i wanted to go to the texas
schools
that was that was back in the old
southwest conference days do you
remember those days yeah yeah i do did
the texas schools recruit you
uh no no they didn't
both my parents went to texas a m so i i
wanted to be an aggie
even though the reputation for the
aggies back then with quarterbacks was
it's where quarterbacks go to die
according to that graveyard it was
running back running back and linebacker
you
but still i love the tradition i wanted
to be an aggie oh
how much of that hurt that all of a
sudden
you don't hear from them
well
ironically my
left tackle in high school
was offered by a m as like a sophomore
he was he was a phenom his name was seth
mckinney his older brother steve
mckinney
was actually it was was a alignment
there at the time
ended up playing in the league for a
long time both those guys did
and so
i went on an unofficial visit to a m my
senior year
and
their seth's parents were pretty
influential with a m as his dad was the
chancellor at a m and so they were
really pushing the aggies to recruit me
and so i think it was just out of
respect for them that the aggies kind of
made it seem like they were
a little bit interested and so they
when i was on this unofficial visit they
scheduled an official visit for me in
january
and so a week before the official visit
i call because i haven't heard a peep
from a m
i said hey am i still coming on this
visit they said oh yeah we'll uh we'll
call you right back
and
it never calls back
so
yeah listen it makes for a good story
now you know but but things things
things probably would have been quite
different had i gone to a m and
not the spread offense at purdue when
did it hit you that you're not playing
football any longer
um
i mean
it's not like you just wake up one day
and say hey i think i'm gonna retire i
mean that that's a that that's a process
um especially as i got you know later in
my career i knew that i was
closer to the end in the beginning and
so you begin to think about how that's
gonna transpire and
you know the feelings and emotions that
go along with that but like the weekends
you know with no football but you're
covering it but
does it do you wake up and you're like
oh god i'm not i'm not playing or i i
i'm not preparing whereas i mean it was
part of your life for decades
yeah
i mean listen it's a grind
you know i mean preparing preparing to
go play a game is a grind and and now it
provides a weekly routine and it
provides habits
that i think really
[Music]
um make you feel make you feel good you
know make you feel like you're going out
and earning what you're going to get on
sundays and so there's definitely
something to that
but honestly what fills that void for me
now is is
coaching my kids and watching my kids
play and and still staying
staying in tune with the game obviously
with broadcasting and with some of the
things i'm doing with nbc so
so there's there's there's ways that i'm
filling that void
toughest thing to get used to as a
member of the media
well i don't really consider myself a
member of the media um even though i
guess you know technically i am
um
i i still i still i try to approach it
the same way i did as a player i i
i still prepare very much the same way
in the way that i'm watching film and
what i'm looking for
and what then i try to communicate to
the fans
so
maybe i'm just taking a different
approach to it
we had a conversation yesterday and uh
we were wondering what you would say to
this
are you uh do you think you're better
than tom brady
that's not fair
um
there there are
let me just say like this
there's no
you can't you can't match up with the
championships right i mean look at look
at just just stop the conversation right
there the guys won seven championships i
mean it's
and you can go to each one and it's very
unique that
my career is coincided almost exactly
with his you know he came out a year
before me
um from michigan you know we played
against each other in college
but uh
but certainly he's always been a guy
that i've you know watched
respected admired
um you know pull up their game tape
watch them i mean so many
so many elements of his preparation and
his
his process
in getting ready to play that i feel
like i i
i know quite a bit about um
so for that reason so much respect and
admiration
um
listen i'll be honest there's
i think each
each quarterback and you could say this
about peyton manning you can say this
about the
aaron rodgers you could say this about
the guys that came before us
you know like the dan marino's and
elways and kind of that era each each
era of football kind of especially with
quarterbacks i think kind of stands
alone i don't think it's fair to
compare this era quarterback with the
errors that came before us just because
there's differences in the rules there's
differences in the environment just all
those things
there are things that i look at and say
you know tom brady does this better than
anybody that i've ever seen
i could say that about peyton manning i
could say that about aaron rodgers i can
say that about myself
there's things that i think that i did
better than anybody
so
that's the way i look at it is
there's elements of everyone's game that
probably set them apart from everybody
else
yeah because he has the resume but the
competitor in you still would feel like
i mean you didn't get to
you know on the doorstep of the hall of
fame without having belief in yourself
you know if somebody said hey are you
better than bob costas at certain things
i am he's got the resume he's got all of
the sports emmys but in my mind
i i feel like hey i'm i can do things
that he can't do and vice versa
exactly so
and there and there's this
there's this competitive edge that
exists with
with guys
when you're when you're
you know in in the
like when you're in the mix when you're
in the moment when you're when you're
playing the game right like i always
felt like
especially maybe with quarterbacks in
the nfl that we would all have even
closer relationships if it wasn't for
the game
it is just so competitive and and we
want we want to beat each other you know
we want to be better than than that
other guy you know and and i think we
we recognize the areas where someone
might be better than us
you know like i can turn on the film and
say man i recognize where brady's better
than me or where rogers is or peyton or
you know one of these guys and yet so
what do i have to do
to get an edge on them right or
and obviously we're not
playing against each other in a game but
at the same time we are
because my performance has to be better
than his performance in order for us to
win this game right so
so yeah you that's how you that's how
you develop an edge i mean that's how
you develop your strategy
for how you're going to need to approach
the game or approach your performance in
order to be better
talking to drew brees his alma mater is
playing notre dame coming up uh this
saturday at 7 30 eastern and of course
football night in america it's 7 eastern
on sunday that'll be the chiefs and the
ravens last time you spoke to jameis
winston was when
i talked to him after the game
did um did you talk to him before the
game
uh we'll text
you know i'm i'm in touch with him and
taste them quite a bit
throughout training camp for pre-season
and
and during the season
are you an unofficial assistant coach
um
i will say this i did have the game plan
for the game in my hand
wait did you write it up
okay okay
the saints gave it to you
yeah the saints gave it to me
um how's notre dame looking by the way
you know what
they're uh they're finding ways to win
i'll say that um
you know they they they open up the
season down at florida state which you
know fans are back hostile environment
obviously florida state was was geeked
out for that game
you know notre dame goes up by was it 18
points in the fourth quarter and then
really allows
allows for state to get back in that
game and tie it and then it goes to
overtime and notre dame finds a way to
win that game really should have been
much more convincing for notre dame that
they just let them back in
they played toledo at home this last
weekend and honestly toledo should have
beat him yeah toledo outplayed it yeah
but listen
what do what do good teams do they find
a way to win even if they're not playing
their best football
i'd say this about notre dame it's a
different team than it was last year
uh they lost uh a lot of i mean unless
they had like nine guys drafted right so
both four out of their five offensive
linemen a couple key defensive starters
so to me they're still trying to find
their identity on on both sides of the
ball
both offensively and defensively you
know they they get jack cohn a
graduate transfer from wisconsin he's
done a great job for them
they've got this young true freshman
quarterback and tyler buckner who came
in against toledo and
was electric
in in what he was able to do
defensively they have a new defensive
coordinator marcus freeman who is
bringing in this aggressive style of
defense he's defensive coordinator
cincinnati prior to this
so you're seeing a lot more variation in
what they're doing pressure
etc but they just haven't quite found
their identity yet i think a lot of it's
just based on hey who
where do our strengths fly you know
what's our personnel look like and then
how are we going to develop the system
around that
how's the city of new orleans after
hurricane ida
it's uh it it's on the rebound as as new
orleans always finds a way to do it so
resilient and and people band together
and and just want to come back you know
this was
this was such a sudden deal you know the
way that ida just picked up in force and
and hit and hit new orleans and really
all of south louisiana and i think the
major issue was the power the power
outages you know and just the what that
causes you know schools
many cases kids haven't gone back to
school a lot of families have been
displaced that's the college high school
all the way down um
you know the new orleans saints are in
dallas right now
practicing i think for another week or
two
and have been since the storm
so
just
so many so many ramifications i know
that line a lot uh you know power line
workers are just working around the
clock sleeping in their cars down in
south louisiana to try to restore power
you know we're working with a bunch of
organizations like convoy pope and
second harvest food bank and others to
to get get a lot of these people food
resources the things they need in order
to restore power so we get families back
in their homes and
schools back
going again and so it's just
the challenges that come along with that
uh here's a little tip if your alma
mater beats notre dame don't jump up and
say we won okay
yeah they're they're trying to coach the
wii out of my my lingo when it comes to
purdue and and the saints you know yeah
yeah you can't say we can't
uh yeah that's hard
no cheering no cheering in the press box
all right
awesome i you know what i found myself i
mean even last week i i just i find
myself cheering for like really just
good sound football and and off you know
some offensive fireworks and i like
seeing i like seeing you know good
schemes on offense good concepts good
execution
so i i find myself cheering for
whoever's on offense
safe travels uh we'll be watching on
saturday night and uh great to catch up
with you again drew
bye dan you too thank you
that's drew brees he'll be on the call
that game is a saturday at 2 30 eastern
and then uh sunday night at 7 eastern
with football night in america